I really liked doing physical things I
didn't play a lot of sports or anything
I guess I wasn't very competitive but I
liked how theater and acting could offer
me a a way to do crazy physical stuff
and Sean Levy who I'd known in college
had seen me do a lot of stuff like that
I can't do a lot of that stuff anymore
cuz I'm getting old and I injured myself
a
[Music]
lot so I've always been physically
comfortable doing stuff like that in
front of people I mean there's obviously
an exhibitionist element to actors that
you kind of don't care or think about it
or you like it like love scenes are
harder to do than like physical shtick
like that I've having had to do a lot of
love scenes so it's all right